so inszeniert die Propaganda den
russischen Präsidenten bei seinem Besuch
in Mariupol als volksnahen Herrscher
das ist alles Lüge das ist für die Show
ruft eine Frau fast unmerklich im
Hintergrund
die Risse im System Putin sind nicht nur
in den besetzten Gebieten sichtbar so
berichtet der ukrainische Geheimdienst
im TV davon dass im Kreml die
Unzufriedenheit wachse und ein
Nachfolger für Putin gesucht werden
sollte Putin durch eine Niederlage in
der Ukraine geschwächt werden wird es
viele Menschen geben die Ihnen loswerden
wollen
auf diese Weise für ihre eigenen Sünden
zu bezahlen
Michael
borisovicsten desidenten Russlands in
London einst war er der reichste Mann
des Landes bis Putin ihn für zehn Jahre
hinter Gitter brachte mit seiner
Organisation open Russia kämpft er nun
aus dem Exil für ein demokratisches
Russland
seit dem Krieg gegen die Ukraine stellt
er sich Putin noch entschlossene
entgegen
am 24.2 vergangenen Jahres begann
ukrainische Städte zu bombardieren
verwandelte er sich in meinem Kopf vom
politischen opponten zum Feind
putinstage sind gezählt davon ist Frau
dokowski überzeugt doch was kommt danach
darüber hat er ein Buch geschrieben wie
man einen Drachen tötet Handbuch für
angehende revolutionäre so der Titel
[Musik]
wir stehen vor zwei gefährlichen
Abgründen
der eine ist die Rückkehr eines Super
zentralisierten totalitären Regimes
der andere ist der völlige Zusammenbruch
des Landes in
der Region
die russische Geschichte ist für
horakowski wie ein Teufelskreis erst
erträgt das Volk das quälende Joch des
Drachen dann kommt ihre Worte das Volk
besiegt den Drachen legt sich nach
kurzer Zeit jedoch einen neuen zu
[Musik]
es ist diese Idee dass wir einfach nur
einen neuen Zaren auswählen müssen und
dass dieser Zar dann eine Demokratie
errichten wird doch genau das ist der
Weg in eine neue Diktatur Novic Diktatur
schon einmal lag die Hoffnung auf Wandel
auf nur einer Person Boris Jelzin doch
aus dem ersten demokratisch gewählten
Präsidenten Russlands wurde schnell ein
Despot der Gegner im Parlament mit
Panzern beschießen und Oligarchen den
Wirtschaftskurs vorgeben ließ
rudakowski profitierte von diesem System
wurde Chef der Ölfirma Jokos
unterstützte Jelzin
1999 ernannte der herzkranke Jelzin
Putin zum Nachfolger der versprach
Jelzin im Gegenzug Straffreiheit für
Handlungen während seiner Amtszeit so
ebnete die Phase demokratische
Hoffnungen am Ende einem allein
Herrscher wie Putin den Weg
wahrscheinlich
der wichtigste Aspekt der darüber
entscheidet ob Russland demokratisch
wird oder stets aufs Neue in den
Teufelskreis des Autoritarismus
zurückfällt ist daher die Frage nach dem
System der checks and balances also der
staatlichen Gewaltenteilung
und zwar von Tag 1 ab einem
Regimewechsel
Spiro vignia smirner
kowski hat am eigenen Leib erfahren wie
schnell schrankenloser macht in Willkür
umschlägt
2003 kritisiert er Putin vor laufenden
Kameras kurze Zeit später landet er für
zehn Jahre hinter Gittern wegen
angeblicher Steuerhinterziehung und
Betrug
um den Drachen ein für alle Mal zu töten
und Russland aus der autoritären
Sackgasse herauszuführen fordert
hodokowski eine Revolution die die
Grundfesten einer traditionellen Ordnung
die stets auf die Macht einzelner
zugeschnitten war umstößt
allein ein Föderalismus mit starken
Regionen können dauerhaft mit der
Zentralmacht des Krems brechen in einem
politischen Verband der Mega Städte
sieht vorderkowski die Zukunft und
findet Vorbilder in der Geschichte
noch vor dem Zaren tun entstanden im 9
jahrhundert zahlreiche selbstverwaltete
und unabhängige Städte in Osteuropa die
von skandinavischen Kriegern und
Händlern gegründet worden
das Reich der Städte
das Gleichgewicht von Interessen
zwischen Ballungsräumen bedeutet ein
System der gegenseitigen Kontrolle das
dazu beitragen kann das Land vor einem
neuen Totalitarismus zu bewahren
mit Öl will der frühere Magnat einen
Paradigmenwechsel erreichen bislang
bezahlen Unternehmen aus dem Gewinn der
mit Rohstoffen erwirtschaftet wird
Milliarden an den Staat horakowski
schlägt vor dieses Geld direkt auf die
Renten und krankenversicherungskonten
der BürgerInnen zu überweisen so dass
sich der Staat damit nicht die Loyalität
der Bevölkerung erkaufen kann
in Russland bezieht die Regierung ihr
Geld nicht von den Bürgern
sondern aus den Einkünften der
rohstoffrente
die Regierung verteilt diese dann wie
ihr Eigentum
so entsteht der Eindruck dass nicht die
Menschen die Regierung finanzieren
sondern sie von der Regierung finanziert
werden
diesen Zustand müssen wir verändern wird
doch um diese Vision zu verwirklichen
wird friedlicher Protest allein nicht
ausreichen davon ist vorderkowski
überzeugt der Widerstand organisiert
sich derzeit im Untergrund so hat die
Organisation des inhaftierten
oppositionelleni vor wenigen Monaten zur
Gründung eines partisanennetzwerks
aufgerufen es sei nur eine Frage der
Zeit bis sich die Opposition bewaffne
ter
wird Putin auf natürliche Weise sterben
oder es kommt zum gewaltsamen Protest
Natur
ich hoffe dass eine Androhung von Gewalt
beide Seiten an den verhandlungste
springt was hättest du billiger geworden
nur
aber ohne die Drohung Gewalt gegen Putin
anzuwenden wird es bis zu seinem Tod
keinen regime-wechsel geben
horakowski will keine politische Rolle
in einem zukünftigen Russland sondern
als Manager die Strippen ziehen
Russlands brauche keine neuen
Hoffnungsträger sondern kollektive
Kräfte die einen Systemwechsel
vorbereiten im besten Fall ist so auch
kein Held mehr nötig der den Drachen ein
für alle mal erledigt